thank you
as people are going to figure out in
about seven seconds your accent is not
Hungarian so what brings a guy like you
to a country like this
well I I see the political future of
conservatism in America is being worked
out here in Hungary in Budapest and
that's fascinating to me I first came to
Budapest around 2018 on a book tour but
also I came a year later to do research
for my book live not by lies which is
about the message that people who
survive communism in Europe Soviet
communism the message they have for us
in the west today about the new softer
totalitarianism that they see emerging
and uh I thought it was really
exaggerated when they first started
telling me this about I don't know eight
nine years ago but the more I listened
to them I'm talking about America these
immigrants the more I listen to them the
more I realize they were seeing
something that was completely oblivious
we Americans were oblivious too and so I
came to travel throughout the former
Soviet block Hungary Poland other
countries to talk to those who had
stayed behind and were dissidents to
find out what do we need to know know
and uh they're so sensible in this part
of the world and they really know to use
a phrase what time it is so I thought
you know what I want to live here and
learn what I can from these people and
try to bring the lessons that I've
learned about politics and about culture
and the fight we're in to try to make it
better known to my own people back in
America plus it's just a great place to
live well the view ain't bad from up
here what is it specifically though
about hungarians or Hungarian culture
that seems to be leading this because
there's obviously plenty of other
countries bordering right here that
maybe aren't doing it quite as well
there seems to be something happening
right here the difference is Victor
Orban the Prime Minister here you don't
hear this at all in the American Media
he's demonized this sort of fascist who
is an authoritarian crushing his country
that was the received opinion I had the
first time I came here in 2018. I was
here to speak at a conference on
religious liberty after the conference
was over we were told that the primary
ownership would like to see meet some of
the speakers I went in there thinking
it's going to be a meet and greet shake
to shake hands with them here if you can
phrases and off we go that man spent 90
minutes talking to us taking our
questions in good English he was warm he
was funny and he you could tell he had
really thought about these things the
Americans there we couldn't believe it
you would never hear that from any of
our politicians left and right the
ability to think on your feet and to
have thought deeply about these issues
Victor Orban I've come to find out since
then I've met him a couple more times
and read more about him now that I live
here I mean he's everywhere here's a man
who is a real Visionary and Americans
just don't know about it because our
media and the Republican establishment
are keeping him at arm's length but when
I invite Americans over I meet like meet
you coming over here if you meet Orban
or if you spend any time in Hungary you
realize he is not and this country is
not what we're told and it back this guy
I think sees the future for the right
it's so interesting because the way the
media permeates everything even if you
somehow intellectually know something's
not true I find sometimes you have to
see it for yourself I told you I just
spent 15 minutes with him by chance we
walked over there and he was able to say
hi friendly warm and just immediately
just wanted to tell me why he loves this
country and in essence to distill it
down he basically said it's our country
and we don't want to be told how to live
and I thought man
oh we could use a little of that
absolutely in America I obviously it has
speech at CPAC both in Dallas last year
and here in Hungary uh recently and uh
his speech really does contain the
things that we American conservatives
need in order to revitalize conservatism
here uh in our country he was talking
about how the virus he calls it a virus
of wokeness gender ideology of open
borders migration all of it is designed
to dissolve the nation-state and to
dissolve peoples if we are going to hold
on to what makes us who we are we need
to stand up against it call it out for
what it is and don't be fooled by it the
thing that Orban sees that so many
American conservatives don't is that the
left has colonized every institution of
civil society when I talked to
hungarians about what's happened to our
military to the CIA to Big Business and
to every other institution they really
can't believe believe it Orban saw a
long time ago that this was happening
and he knew that the only way
traditional conservatives could stand up
to what the ngos George Soros and all
the other worksters and open borders
people were doing was to use politics in
an aggressive way we don't see that in
our country Ron DeSantis is the only one
in our country at the senior level of
Republican leadership who seems to get
that do you think that can be expanded
throughout America I mean we talked
about it a bit at the event last night
but you know I'm living it literally
living it in Florida and it changed my
life I had to move 3000 miles from
California to Florida I see it happen
here do you think that can be replicated
properly in America or our politics too
too calcified no it can but we have to
be careful I mean we were talking last
night you and I about Israel and Hungary
and their success stories one of the
things that makes their politics play
out the way they do is they have an
underlying sense of national Unity I
mean here in Hungary it is a homogeneous
country ethnically and culturally and
that matters I mean of course they are
really harsh political disputes here but
ultimately they have this sense of this
is where the tribe lives the Najar tribe
we've been here for a thousand years and
we have to keep our country going the
United States is a much more diverse
place and that's not there's nothing
wrong with that it's just it is what it
is and it's why you can't just pick up
orbanism and plug it into America but
what we can do and what we have to do is
unite our country America around the
principles of the Constitution you know
and not to be afraid to talk about the
importance of free speech and things
that are in the Bill of Rights that are
under constant attack by the woke we can
defend those things but we also have to
understand that using the the standard
methods of Defense which is what the
Republican party has been offering ain't
going to work anymore because things
changed in the great awokening all of
the institutions are lined up against us
when you see what DeSantis is doing in
Florida by going in taking on what
capitalism with Disney and trying to get
Dei and wokeness out of the schools
that's pure Orban and it's the only
thing that's going to work yeah where do
you see uh the the pushback here I've
been trying to figure out you know it's
very easy for me to diagnose what's
going on with r left in America it's
sort of it really has become radicalized
and I wish there was a good left that we
could debate with honestly it just
doesn't seem to exist what's the sort of
temperature on that here yeah it's I
hesitate to to speak too boldly because
I don't speak Hungarian yet and uh so I
I miss a lot of the Nuance in the local
debates but generally speaking the left
in Hungary is run by a man named drason
who at the time of the fall of Communism
was ahead of the Communist Youth League
he's still the the big guy in left-wing
politics here and by the way seven years
after the fall of Communism this guy
became one of the richest men in Hungary
funny how that happened you don't say
you know what I'm saying and so a lot of
the people who remember communism
they're totally on orban's side because
he was a very brave student
anti-communist leader you can go on
YouTube and find this video of a speech
he gave in 1988 as communism was falling
they were re-bearing a man who was a
communist leader in 1956 at the time of
the Soviet invasion but he was a patriot
and the Soviets hanged him imranage was
his name Orban as a student leader he's
got a mullet and all that he's totally
80s he gave this very brave speech in
which he told the Soviets to get the
hell out of their country this was a
time when communism was still ruling
this country and that became the basis
for his later political career
so the left today in Hungary is still
run by this old-fashioned communist but
they've smoothed things out and now
they're property bureaucrats meaning
they won't rule from Brussels they want
open borders they want George Soros and
all the whole package
the lucky thing for this country is
they're completely disorganized I was
here last year 2022 for the election
which or Bonnet his fetus party won over
Wellness yeah a landslide and they
weren't supposed to win living here in
Hungary knowing hungarians talking to
ordinary hungarians in the bar in the
coffee shop the taxi many of them
complained about this or that about
Orban anybody after 12 years and power
is going to happen but in the end it all
came down to but of course I'm in a vote
for him have you seen the left because
they're completely incompetent they had
this guy who was there a guy named
Marquis zoy he was their standard Bearer
in 2022. he gave this uh this comment he
said we're the true diverse Coalition we
have communist and fascists in the
Coalition which was true but you're not
supposed to say that
coming to our Democrat Party yeah get
get this Dave the media the Western
media did not report that at all they
would only come to Budapest talk to
Buddha has some liberals and they
totally missed everything they thought
that because Orban was opposed to NATO's
policy in Ukraine that oh the hungarians
are going to throw them out no he spoke
for them they don't want war
so when I chatted with him just briefly
a moment ago I asked him about how he
deals with the media and he kind of
laughed it off like he just it seems
clear to me he simply does not care do
you think that really is the
prescription for all of this that that
we need more political leaders who just
don't care yes yes that's it he's so
confident and he's so smart that's the
thing he's not a crude brutish guy he
says what's on his mind he had a smile
on his face the entire time it was so
contrasted with what you hear of the guy
exactly and he's a brilliant man he
knows what he believes and he's also
ready to fight he fights constantly some
hungarians say maybe he's too quick to
start a fight but I tell you I'd rather
have that than the Republicans we have
who are willing to roll over at every
turn and as much as uh Victor Orban
loves Donald Trump the huge difference
between Orban and Trump is Orban
believes a lot of the things Trump does
but he also knows how to turn those
beliefs into policy he's got discipline
and he's got political skills this is
why I Look to to scientists I try to
tell my Hungarian Francis DeSantis is
the successor to Orban or the American
version of Orban yeah interesting all
right so one more for you as as a new
guy in this country uh what would you
tell people that are watching this going
boy I should probably spend a little
more time there I would say come over
here there's no substitute for actually
coming to Hungary and seeing for
yourself when Americans come over I tell
them one of the first things you need to
know is the international media and the
Washington establishment treat Hungary
the same way conservatives are treated
in the United States you know you're
nothing but a bunch of bigots and
backwards deplorables when you actually
get here to Hungary you see it ain't
true it's not true at all and the more
time you spend here you realize how
blessedly normal this country is low
crime you know they have dissent and and
they struggle here it's a normal country
in that sense but it's also a stable
country and one of the reasons uh almost
alone among European capitals that
Budapest is so safe is because Orban
would not allow open migration I
remember going to Paris in the summer
2021 I was here in Budapest on a
fellowship I went to Paris on a book
tour and everybody was afraid then
because there was lots of Palestinian
and Islamic radicalism going on
anti-semitic attacks people in Paris
were all talking about is this the start
of a Civil War and I realized oh my God
the aurobond was right if you allow open
borders and you allow people who hate
your society and who don't want to
integrate to come in this is what
happens they're never going to get rid
of that problem come here to Hungary
learn how they do it and go back to
America with a sense of vision Tucker
Carlson got this Vision Dave he came
here in 2021 saw for himself how
different this can country was to the
way it's presented in the American Media
and he changed the narrative at the
Grassroots level about Hungary we saw
what happened to Tucker there are a lot
of powerful people in America who don't
want American conservatives to pay any
attention to Hungary much less come here
and learn any lessons from it I'm here
to tell you and I'm glad you're here
it's not what they say come see for
yourself yeah and I suspect we have not
heard the last from Tucker please God
Rod it was great to see you thanks babe
yeah if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell